today's hottest music bootleg cab juicy
little live in studio this guy is one of
the most talked about guys online right
now a good friend of mine man we got the
homie casper smart in the building hey
hey casper you are uh man you got the
movie coming out honey too which is it's
already out everywhere in the in the
world we were just talking about this
but it'll be uh coming out
anyway february is gonna be coming out
here on dvd yes we don't get it
we don't get it i mean i'm upset but i'm
upset too i will say this is probably
knowing because i you know i'm i'm uh
i'm a connoisseur of all things pirating
movies uh all that it's probably already
online
i'm sure it is it probably is so juicy
if you want it let me know you got it is
jessica alba back no no we have a
katarina graham she's hot
i'll take it okay okay i'm not mad at
that so of course you're you're a big
dancer you do a lot of choreography
you've worked with a lot of people uh
eminem
beyonce mike posner that's actually how
i met you yeah yeah um what is like uh
the the uh
the best part about
choreography to me is so confusing man
like how does somebody sit back and like
think of
dance routines like that's it's crazy um
you know
i think it has to do a lot with the
music so the music
is good it's always easier to move you
so when you have like an idea in your
head you have to like is it kind of like
a lot of artists they write to beats do
you have to like hear the music to to to
get the dance down i guess
uh
sometimes well sometimes i just
i don't know i'm weird with that
people are all different on how they did
it but
um i could be in the grocery store and i
could just feel like this little step
and i will stop and catch it i don't
care if people look at me crazy
i will make up those quick little steps
real quick and i'll be like a little
right mental note
he's like recording himself on his
iphone to make sure he remembers it i'm
telling you man it because it just
sometimes comes to you and you're like
oh that's a hot step i got to keep that
and use it for something but um
i don't know you know most of the time i
get it i like to get a track at least a
week before i choreograph something
right if it's like a video or whatnot
and um or a show
and uh i choreographed my room it's like
i don't like to be in a studio until
it's time to like teach the dancers or
artists or whatever um i like to
choreograph in my bedroom i have like a
huge room and i like um i have these
little mirrors i put up and it's real
weird but it's like the only place i'm
comfortable
the mirrors could also come in handy for
other reasons too
sure
but who has been the hardest to teach
who's kind of slow to teach
um
storm out there
it's my closure huh no it seems pretty
good uh mike's not a dancer he doesn't
he doesn't like the dance right
he doesn't like that dancer he just
likes um
to have like a movement coach is what i
do for him i just do kind of staging a
movement so i give him like a little
easy little step here there for certain
um
you know beats in his music
um but i mean everyone else like
uh
beyonce the beast oh yeah beyonce is
crazy eminem was actually surprisingly
good pretty good really yeah which video
did you do for me i did we made you okay
elvis yeah i went you did the who run
the world choreography uh well there was
like eight different choreographers
because that's one of my when she what
award show did she perform that on with
the screen
mtv yo that was like one of the craziest
yeah yeah yeah she's phenomenal of
course you have been
on every tabloid as of late man your
life is kind of i can imagine taking a
lately uh what what's it like man and
the first time i met you with mike
posing a few like i was like what six
months ago something like that september
it was september
um to now
how are you dealing with all the
attention my man
um you know i'm doing my best uh
like like i said i kind of just
kind of stay in the shadows if i can
um if i'm not on a job
you know i go out here and there we're
very
slim to none now just because there's
just too much hype and don't want to
deal with anything and all that
crazy stories people make up and you
don't want to whip a paparazzi's ass you
know they're crazy man but um they're
just you know trying to make a dollar
like everybody else i guess
um
i don't know you know it's it's just
real nutty right now so i'm just trying
to keep my head
on straight and stay focused on what i
do and uh not my not lose myself with uh
the extra correct
extracurriculars
that's what's up man so uh what else you
got up on the horizon coming up are you
got the honey movie coming up with
anything else you're working on
yeah man uh well i'm in i'm in this
transition um
you know just just working on
uh this acting thing so i kind of fell
back on the dancing and not really doing
that too much anymore um just doing my
choreography thing and um
and working with the working on the
acting
so um taking classes for that yeah yeah
i'm i'm getting i'm starting to take
classes for that you know it's just a
training process starting all over with
kind of a new field
um and then i got a couple videos
coming up that i'm choreographing for
some upcoming artists and then i think
miguel
um i have a meeting with this director
for his upcoming video that i might be a
part of oh nice we were talking about
him off the air actually yeah yeah he's
dope
we'll see are you staying busy man yeah
man gotta stay busy right staying busy
all right we're gonna go we're gonna let
you go i know you got a crazy uh you
gotta you gotta go hit them tables at
the palazzo what do you play
you know i play craps i'm not a huge
gambler but i like to roll the dice a
couple times and then
you know if i lose a couple hundred
dollars and i'm like oh okay let's get
out of here before i get caught up
because you always want to try to break
even at least
once you get down you're like nah if i
keep playing i'm gonna be good i just
gotta keep going you're down 200 400 600
and then you're like dang i just lost a
thousand in this hour
so yeah you know yeah that's cause i do
it you know just for a little plan hey
well we appreciate you coming in man i
know you said a lot of people have been
trying to interview you absolutely and
you turned them down so that's right you
know olay cavs building i appreciate the
love man shout out to casper smart hit
him on twitter at casper smart
uh yeah yeah i'm sure he's getting all
the twitter love right now anyway so hit
him up it's going down man it's hot 975
wait you got a website too right
caspersmart.com there it is man hit him
up
shout out to you thank you sir thanks
casper thanks juicy thanks bootleg
bootleg